>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Gail Shirazi: I'm Gail Shirazi.
Welcome to today's program,
"Super Hero: Hebrew Superheroes
with Filmmakers Asaf Galay."
In conversation with Georgia Higley,
the program is sponsored by MBRS
at the Library, The
Washington Jewish Film Festival,
and the Hebrew Language
Table here at LC.
A special thanks to Iliad Tovas,
head of the Washington Jewish
Film Festival, Audrey Fischer
of our Public Affairs
Office, Galina Teverovsky
and Haim Gottschalk
[phonetic] of the IJ Section,
The Embassy of Israel,
and Georgia Higley,
who's head of our newspaper
section of the Serial
and Government Publications
Division, and who's a curator
of the comic section
-- comic books section.
Asaf has written and
directed a number
of award-winning documentaries
on Israeli television,
including a series on Israeli
[inaudible], history of Tel Aviv,
Jaffa, and the life and
influence of Joseph Trumpeldor.
Last year, at the Washington
Jewish Festival,
he screened his documentary
"Muses of Isaac Bashevis Singer"
on the Yiddish writer,
Bashevi Singer.
In addition to his film work,
he curates for Beit Hatfutsot,
which is a museum for the Jewish
people in Tel Aviv, Israel.
He's doing exhibits on Jewish
humor, Jewish fashion designers,
the Dreyfus affair, the
Amy Winehouse Exhibit,
which I saw when I was in Israel,
and a new one on Bob Dylan.
He's currently working
on a film on Sal Bellows.
And I must say, he was happily
using our collections at LC.
Speaking of resources at LC,
I've brought out a few comic
graphic novels that we have
in our Hebraic collections.
And before we start, a few
words from Lihi Shavit-Saguy,
who is the cultural attaché
at the Israeli Embassy.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Lihi Shavit-Saguy: It's
going to be very few words
because I'm curious, as you are,
to hear what Asaf has to say.
I just want to thank you
for being here today.
I want to thank Gail for initiating
this program, as she does always.
She did an interesting
and fascinating program
regarding Israeli literature
and Hebrew literature.
And I hope you'll enjoy this
event, and this lecture, and clips.
It sounds fascinating to me.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> Asaf Galay: Thank you for coming.
I hope that you will enjoy the
lecture and the conversation,
and mostly, the clips because as
a filmmaker, [laughter] my best is
to show my film than to talk.
[Laughs]
>> Georgia Higley:
Before we get started,
I just want to put a little plug
in for our comic book collection,
because it's probably one of the
better kept secrets of the Library.
And it's unfortunate that that's
the case, because we have one
of the largest collections
in the country.
And anybody who's interested in
doing serious research on Superman,
Archie, Detective Comics, or Zapp,
you can find them all
in our division.
So I encourage anybody who's
interested in doing research
with comic books to
come to the newspaper
and current periodical
reading room, and talk to us,
because we would welcome using
our -- with our collection, okay?
So now we're going to take a turn,
and it's going to be a conversation
that Asaf and I were going to have.
And hopefully, the questions will
give him an opportunity to kind
of sort of inform us on how
we can come about writing --
creating this documentary,
but also giving us some --
a close look on, you know,
what are Israeli comics,
because I frankly didn't know very
much about them until I had a chance
to spend some time with him.
So I'd like to start the questions.
And hopefully, we can
just take it from there
and have a wonderful dialogue.
So my first question to
you is you've been working
on some very different
film topics, I mean,
Isaac Bashevis Singer,
Hebrew superheroes.
They seem a little
disparate in content.
So what attracted you to
those very different topics?
And is there something that kind of
links those topics together for you?
>> Asaf Galay: Okay, [laughs] okay.
First I think the answer for your
question, it's my childhood love.
When I was young, I was
always fascinated from comics,
and from the children books of Isaac
Bashevis Singer that are beautiful
and illustrated by Moe
Sanduck [phonetic].
And maybe I'm a little bit a docent.
So I was -- later on, I was
still reading it when I grew up.
And about Isaac Bashevis
Singer, I was one day --
I will tell you in a
short the whole film,
that I found that when I finished
his Hebrew book and I started
to read all his short stories in
English, I found out that in each
of his short book, another name
of a woman is credited
for being a translator.
So I said, "It's fascinating.
Okay; this is a mystery.
I will start to count how
many names there are."
And then I found out 48 women.
[Laughter] So this is my researching
and my mystery detective.
So I try to -- I started to
call them and to ask them, "Wow,
why do you have 48
women translators?
Why not one?
When you have a good
translator, go with her."
So this would be --
so then now you need
to see the film why he had this
hound of women translators.
And about comics, I have
always loved comics.
And first really when I grew up,
I read the American superheroes,
Spiderman, Batman, Superman.
And for me, it was mysterious why
and American comic artists that came
to the United States, or came --
most of them from Europe in the '20s
and the '30s, made these
-- innovated this great --
and most of them were Jews --
made these great comics that we
are worldwide known, like Superman,
and Spiderman, and all of them were
made by comics artists like Siegel
and Shuster, Jack Kirby, Stan Lee.
And at the same time, in
Israel came also comic artists,
and they made totally
other protagonists,
the Israeli superheroes.
>> Georgia Higley: So how did
you approach making this film,
since it's about comics and
some of the Hebrew superheroes?
>> Asaf Galay: So first I
contacted all of these people.
And comics artists, when I compare
them to people from the film,
from the literature, will have
very open, very straightforward,
and they like to tell
you great stories.
And so I called them, and
they were really happy
that first time somebody will
make a film about Israeli comics
and will tell the world about that.
And this is my mission in the films
that and then you will want to go
and take a book about falafel
man, or [inaudible] man,
or other kind of characters.
So I took the top ten comic
artists, in my opinion.
Each one of them represents
another style,
another decade in the
Israeli society.
And it also reflects
about the changes
in the Israeli society,
history and culture.
>> Georgia Higley: Okay;
so maybe we can, you know,
sort of look at the
beginning of Israeli comics?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
So I will start with the first
clip that it's the intro clip.
And it's about the
first Israeli superhero.
Okay.
>> Georgia Higley: Yes.
[ Silence ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Asaf Galay: So this
is Eewyian [phonetic],
the first Israeli superhero.
He didn't have any special
forces, but he was --
his mission was to help the new
countries that he's growing up.
And he was very -- it was a
funny twist and sometimes,
he had like he could
make himself bigger.
And people loved him.
He was -- for 30 years,
he was in the daily kids.
And I think that he stopped in '67
because it was a big
change in Israel society.
There was -- the '60s were changing
the conception of the Israeli
and this naive and
childhood hero was not good.
And they started to look
for new kinds of heroes.
>> Georgia Higley:
So did they look back
to America for their heroes there?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
So then they started to look
again to the Americans to starting
where Superman is in '67 is
like the well-known character,
and some of them trying
to put Superman
in the Israeli society,
in the Israeli culture.
And there are two attempts for this.
And these attempts
are very interesting.
And I will tell more
after we will see them.
[ Silence ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
[Laughter] Okay.
But then he created another.
[ Background Sounds ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
[ Music ]
[ Silence ]
Asaf Galay: Yes.
So we see that the two Israeli
superman, the subraman [phonetic],
have -- two of them they are
changing the "S" to Jewish symbols,
and are trying to put [inaudible]
in Israeli history culture.
And one of them is a soldier.
And he's fighting Elias.
The other is a subraman.
He's somebody from another universe.
And he has this -- of course, both
of them have like special powers.
And he's fighting the Nazis.
And they are -- both of them
were really interesting.
It's drawn well.
The subraman is not colored.
Eewyian is in color.
But -- and then the
audience didn't --
it was for a short
period both of them went,
and the Israeli audience
didn't like it.
They searched for another
kind of superhero,
superheroes that they can more
identify, something that they feel
that it's giving them
another kind of fantasy,
or something that they
more can relate to it.
>> Georgia Higley: So why do you
think the American style superhero
failed with the Israeli audience?
>> Asaf Galay: I think that
in Israel that they were tired
from heroes, from superheroes
because you can find
it in the daily news.
You can find them.
There is the soldier,
there is the leader,
and there are the Israeli heroes.
So then when it's come
to this subculture,
people want another
kind of superhero.
And then they combined like
they wanted to be something
that they're more identified
from reality.
And then it's something
really strange is coming up.
And this is like a connection, maybe
because of that I like them so much,
it's they are taking the
protagonist, the totally other side
of the superhero, it's the loser.
They are taking the ultimate
loser, like it's the protagonist
in the Yiddish literature
in Shalamalech
and Isaac Bashevisinger [phonetic].
So they're taking the complete
-- maybe they are brothers.
One is -- there is this movie,
"Twins", like one is Schwarzenegger,
the other is Danny De Vito.
So they are taking
this loser character,
and they are making him like a hero.
But this loser is sometimes he's
failing, but a lot of times,
he's also succeeding to solve the
mystery, the problem, the motive.
>> Georgia Higley: So who are these?
>> Asaf Galay: Who are they?
[Laughter] So I will
show a couple of them.
And okay.
[ Silence ]
I have two jobs.
[Laughs]
[ Silence ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
Well, [laughs] so she's
like taking --
we saw in the first Eewy Meewy
[phonetic], this kids that was --
he was doing tricks, but
he was still like good.
[Laughs] And then she took this
kid and she changed his character.
She made him like that he's the
one that's not that innocent,
that he is very demanding.
And this character of
Chamudi [phonetic],
it's "cutie" in English,
became very popular.
You can meet him in
commercials in Israel.
You can meet him like in doing
a commercial for healthcare.
And people love him
really, and there is --
and this is really one of
the most comics characters
that are loved in Israel.
And it's a really nice twist
to see how it was in the '30s,
this kid character and now in the
2000s, what is the new millennium,
what is the new kid character.
>> Georgia Higley: So if you
had sort of this retelling
of the cute character reappearing,
do you also have a variation
of the superhero appearing then?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
Now it's -- there is new kind
of superheroes in Israel.
In Israel, people love
to read more comics.
It's become more mainstream.
There are stores of
comics you can find.
There is a museum for comics.
There is like every year
two festivals for comics.
And the new generation
loves to read comics.
So they made up two new
Israeli superheroes.
And I think that they are great.
You will meet them in a second.
One is Falafel Man, [laughter]
and the other is Oozy [phonetic].
And they are more complex,
and they --
are combined they're like
kind of a special power,
and also it's kind
of more of a loser.
[Laughs]
[ Background Sounds ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
[ Silence ]
[Laughter] This is Falafel Man.
And he's like the most
popular now among the kids.
And I think that he has a great --
it's like a little bit here of
the story of the Green Giant,
that's he's like enter the
Green Giant to this reactor,
and he got these special powers.
But here the twist is that
he got in with Falafel.
So [inaudible] -- so he can
throw you a new falafel,
but what is done, not a lot.
But still he's solving the
problems of the bad guys
that are coming to attack the good.
And he's really funny.
And this is what I
think what happened.
This was the combination of
the loser and the superheroes.
And it's -- you should read it.
[Laughter] No more.
>> Georgia Higley: So
something else that was in --
is in your documentary is
sort of a category of comics
of retelling Israeli history?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> Georgia Higley: Can you speak
a little bit more about that?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
There is also a great
phenomenon that also later that --
also in the more religious
people they have comics.
And also in the United
States and Israel,
the Orthodox are having comics.
And then they are taking like the
great characters from the Bible,
of the rabbis, and
telling comics about them.
Later on you can find here like
great collections of books of it.
So this is one phenomenon.
And also -- but for me the most
prominent in this field it's a guy
that his name is "Shai
Charkoff" [phonetic].
And he really told the
story of the Bible,
and later of the [inaudible]
in comics.
And he took a character that he --
made up a character
that his name is "Baba".
And it's become a big phenomenon.
And he's telling all
the Jewish history.
Now he's working more
for later and later.
And let's see it.
[ Silence ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
So here [inaudible] and since
then when it comes as to --
as Jews, the story of antiheroes
are much more successful
that we just have a story, because
here he's like writing [inaudible]
that we work, and he says
that, "They are out."
They cannot work in
Israel, and his character,
"Baba", this is the [inaudible].
[Laughs]
[ Background Sounds ]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
So here this is David, the
King, and he fell on Goliath,
and Goliath will follow him.
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
So this is [inaudible].
[Laughter]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
Here he is saying [inaudible]
of the Jewish locals.
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
This is the tenth legs.
[Laughs] So you see that
each leg is happening to him.
[Laughter]
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
Here he says, "This is
like Sigmund Freud."
[Laughter] [Inaudible].
[ Video Clip Plays in Hebrew ]
[ Background Sounds ]
So this is like the comics in the
more -- in the Orthodox society.
We [inaudible] in Israel,
he was a [inaudible] member.
He died recently, but he
was a well-known figure
in the Orthodox society; yes.
>> Georgia Higley: So you've
given us a pretty good picture
of what your documentary's about.
And also I feel like we got
a sense of what the history
of Israeli comics is about,
at least you tantalized us
to want to learn more.
But to shift gears a
little bit, I'm interested
in knowing how you were able to
get the participation that you got
with the comic book creators, and
also the fact that they are so open
and frank in how they
answer their questions.
>> Asaf Galay: Really, the
comic artist was really open
for doing a documentary about it.
The only concern -- and it was
also a very big concern for me,
it's how you move --
how you transform comics to the
big screen, to the television.
So because most of the time
when you are transforming comics
to the big screen, you are doing
2D animation, 3D animation.
And nowadays it's like
reality with special effects.
And they say, "No, no, no; this is
the worst thing for our comics."
Comics, the reading that your
eyes are like the cameras.
If you are doing the focals,
that you can read the text first,
you can move like this,
or like this.
It's so important.
So it was -- also for me it was
-- when I did this small animation
and showed the comics, I
tried to show how it looks,
the feeling of the reading.
And sometimes it makes
this film very condensed,
that you need to look
at the picture,
also to look at the picture.
You need to understand
it takes time.
You need to read.
And also sometimes there
is voiceover of something.
So it's very condensed.
A lot from your patience.
And you need to be very tuned to it.
And I tried to bring it to
the audience this feeling,
because also when you read comics,
it's a very intense experience.
People think, "Eh, it's
only looking at a picture."
Not at all.
Reading comics it's a great
experience, and it takes --
you need to have this
quality how to read comics.
>> Georgia Higley: Okay.
And I want to leave a few
minutes for questions to Asaf,
but I have one more
question for you of my own --
>> Asaf Galay: Okay.
>> Georgia Higley: Before
we open it for questions.
And what are you working on next?
>> Asaf Galay: Oh, so
it's a good question.
So my other film about Isaac
Bashevi Singer, it was about him
and his woman translator.
But his first translators was --
that made him successful
and opened the doors for him
to the English reader was Sol Belo
[phonetic], another [inaudible].
So now I make -- and Isaac Bashevi's
was really afraid from Sol Belo
that everything will think that
he's not such a good writer.
It's only because Sol
Belo helped him.
So because of that, he said, "Okay;
for now I will take a
new kind of translation.
I will do it."
He will take this business
to himself.
So now I'm making a
film about Sol Belo.
It will be a first-time
documentary about him.
And as a filmmaker, you will need
always to work on two project
in the same, [laughs] because
one project is going fast
and then it's stuck, always
money and things like this.
So on the other side, I'm doing
films that's also continuance
of my search more in
this visual world.
It's about the Fleischer
-- the Fleischer studios.
They made up Popeye and Betty Boop,
and all of these great characters.
Also, they are the first
ones that made Superman
to the animation for Superman.
They were the -- in the '20s, '30s,
there were two big major animation
studios, The Fleischer and Disney.
And this was the big rival.
The Fleischer's were, of
course, Jewish immigrants.
It was a family and Disney,
as we know, were not Jewish,
They came from Midwest
America and they won, Disney.
And already they made about
them a great documentary,
ten -- six episodes.
I'm on the Fleischer side.
I think that the Fleischer
cartoons are much better.
I think that this is how you should
do comics, cartoons, animations,
that it's like less
reality, more surrealistic.
And it's a better influence,
like all the --
I don't know, compare
Betty Boop to one of the --
to Snow White, or compare
Popeye to the prince.
So it's -- so I think that their
style -- but they lost in the fight.
So I think it's time to make a
film about them, and why they lost.
[Laughs]
[ Silence ]
>> Georgia Higley: Okay; I'm
going to look forward to it.
So those sound like great projects.
Does anybody have any questions?
All right.
And bear with me because
I'm going to repeat it
for the webcast, all right?
Yes.
>> So the only thing I remember
about Israeli comics is in the '60s,
my grandmother used to send us --
she used to very carefully
cut Ferdinand comics
out of the newspaper.
And we'd get every couple of weeks
all of these Ferdinand comic strips,
newspaper comic strips sent in
one of those blue aerograms.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> And I always thought
that that must have come --
she was from Vienna.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> And I don't know what the
comic strip culture was in Europe
from a lot of the world where the --
a lot of where the World
War II immigrants came from.
But I'm wondering if
there is a connection,
and how that fits into this?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
You could --
>> Georgia Higley: Either
you or more for the question.
>> Asaf Galay: No, you, you.
[Laughter]
>> Georgia Higley: I'm going to try.
Sorry. This is a strip such
as Ferdinand that was clipped
from the newspaper in Vienna.
>> No, no, no; an Israeli newspaper.
>> Georgia Higley: An
Israeli newspaper and sent;
and so what was the connection
between European and
Israeli comic strip?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
So you saw that here in the
movie there are different styles
of comics, like the
style of this more center
of Europe it's very minimalistic.
And there is a big tradition
of it, like the last --
the Hymnodies [phonetic] in these
traditions that you don't make --
the American tradition it's
totally that you are making swap,
and [inaudible], and jumping.
And you have the strip that --
and also the boxes in
the strip are changing.
And in the European style
always it's very minimalistic.
It's one line that the strip
-- the boxes are the same.
And it was also influenced
in Israel,
and also in newspaper it's
also more common to see it.
And yes it was influenced.
And some -- in Israel there were
many influences, from America,
from Europe, from Central
Europe, from --
>> Georgia Higley: Yes.
>> Some of the early comics in
America, the subjects were animals.
A couple that come to mind are
Tom and Jerry, Felix the Cat.
Did that phenomenon also occur
in Israel where the subjects
of the comics were
animals and not people?
>> Georgia Higley: The question
is about how American comics --
>> From the early days.
>> Georgia Higley: The early
days used animals in the comics,
and did something similar
happen with Israel comics?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
There is this -- in Israel they made
-- the figure is called "The Duck".
And he's a loser, the duck.
[Laughter] In each end of the strip,
the butcher is coming
and killing the duck.
But yes, it was also
there, and it was great.
I did -- tonight there is a
screening, and you can come
and see the whole film
and meet the duck.
>> Georgia Higley: Yes.
>> You talked about the big screen,
and obviously here with Hollywood,
Hollywood's been trying to cash
in for the last ten to 20 years,
and even before that in
television in the '30s and '40s.
Have any of the characters
that have been well-known
in Israel made their way to live
action where someone portrays them
as you see that today in Hollywood
with the Batman and
Superman characters?
Are the people reenacting in either
TV or Israeli films those characters
that everybody knows there?
>> Georgia Higley: Have any of
the Israeli characters made it
to either the TV or the silver
screen similar to the way
that the American comics
have made that jump?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
So the guy who we think
that made subraman later on,
he made the comic strips that
it's called "Beng" [phonetic].
And it was -- and it's
still publishing today.
And it's about a teenager,
an Israeli.
It's like Mad Magazine.
It's very, very funny, but
also a little bit satiric.
And this -- and his strip
came to the television,
but not yet to the big screen.
Now they're working on
another guy that made a very --
a graphic novel about the
Holocaust and his experience.
It's like he's very influenced by
Maus [phonetic], and working now
to make a film about him.
His name is Michel
Kichka [phonetic].
And this will be the first time
that they will make an animated
film from an Israeli cartoon.
>> Georgia Higley: Sure.
>> I'd like to ask questions.
One is about [inaudible].
You mentioned a couple
of Nobel Prize winners.
[Inaudible] plays a
very important role.
And I wonder if anybody picked up.
That would make an
interesting presentation
of the dog in the cartoons.
The other question is about Yiddish.
You mentioned at the beginning
the idea of the [inaudible],
the Yiddish [overlapping].
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> And I wondered if anything
has been done in this connection,
and if there is a market in
Israel to read stories in Yiddish.
>> Georgia Higley: Okay;
two -- let's see if I --
I'm not sure if I'm going to be able
to capture all of your question --
your two questions properly.
But there's the one --
>> Asaf Galay: About Agnon.
>> Georgia Higley: Agnon, the dog.
Let's start with that.
>> Asaf Galay: You have a good idea.
They should make a film about it.
[Laughter] Maybe me; I will take it.
>> Georgia Higley: Get his name
so he can get an acknowledgement
about that idea.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
By the way, it's reminded
me, the acknowledgment,
the people that made the Superman,
Schuster and Siegel, for many years,
they were -- never
acknowledged about it.
And there was a big fight about it.
Mind you, of course
they never saw it.
But in there the first movie
"Superman" in '78 or nine,
I don't remember, that came to the
big screen, the first "Superman".
And this was the first time
and after that and until now,
the big studios are making
films about superheroes.
But the first was Superman.
And in the Superman,
they said, "Okay;
now it's time to give
them the acknowledgement."
And they said, "Okay; Superman,
created by Schuster and Siegel."
And now it's not only this
and Marvels that created this
because the comic artists
didn't make a lot of money.
They worked really hard.
And it's a very tragic story.
You can read it.
Also Michael Chabon [phonetic]
wrote a great book about it,
"The Adventure of the
Kavalier & Clay [phonetic]".
So I will not do it.
I will give you credit.
And the --
>> The other one was about Yiddish.
>> Asaf Galay: Ah.
>> If there is a market
for Yiddish --
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> Georgia Higley: A
market for Yiddish?
>> Asaf Galay: So in the
[inaudible] population,
they have comics in Yiddish.
And this is the big heat.
This is going very well.
And they are selling more comics
magazine in the [inaudible].
Like each week there is like
two new magazines very --
really because in Israeli comics,
it's like now the parents like if
in the '50s, they told the
kids, "Don't read comics.
Read real books."
In our days, the parents say,
"Okay, read comics, read something.
Don't watch TV."
[Laughter] They really
encourage them to read that.
So most of the kids in Israel
still watch TV and not read comics.
But still, in the [inaudible],
that they don't want
that they will watch
TV, it's really selling.
And they have Goldberg, this
character that he speaks Yiddish.
And yes it's -- I think
that it's also a good idea
to make a Yiddish superhero
for a movie.
You have great ideas.
You should be a filmmaker.
[Laughter]
>> Georgia Higley:
Okay; the last question.
>> I had a question about
superheroes in politics.
You had Goldemeyer
[phonetic] there on the screen.
What about super losers in politics?
>> Georgia Higley: Super losers,
not just superheroes in politics.
>> Asaf Galay: Oh.
But this is -- you touch really --
Goldemeyer, it's important symbol.
In American society, she's like --
tonight I am going to the National
Jewish Museum in Philadelphia.
So she's one of the top Jewish
figures in the 20th Century.
In Israel they dislike her.
She is not -- because she's
connected to the Yom Kippur
for '73 -- for the Israel
society, Goldemeyer she's a loser.
They don't like her.
So this is the difference.
[ Silence ]
>> Georgia Higley: Okay.
So are there lots of -- is there
political element in comics?
>> Asaf Galay: Yes, yes.
>> Georgia Higley: Okay.
>> Asaf Galay: For sure.
And like always in a
subculture, there is --
it's more criticizing
and satiric comics.
>> Georgia Higley:
Okay, all right, good.
>> I have just one
question too, if I can.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> Was there some pushback when
they did the Holocaust comics
because of the topic?
Did people think it was
not an appropriate form
to discuss the Holocaust?
>> Georgia Higley: Okay.
So was there a pushback when the
Holocaust comics were published?
>> Asaf Galay: So I
think that in '82,
it was published first time Maus.
And this was a breakthrough.
And Maus was saying that you
can tell stories for adults.
You can tell them in
a format of a book,
of a novel graphic you can tell
stories about the Holocaust.
And Maus also was translated
to Hebrew.
And it was changing
also in the comic world.
It made what it's -- there
is now a differentiation
between comics magazines
and graphic novels.
This was Maus.
Maus was the first one.
So this guy, Michel Kishka
[phonetic], that did it,
he did it only four years ago to do
a graphic novel about his experience
as a second-generation
about the Holocaust.
The ground was already
prepared for him to do it.
And it's a great graphic novel.
You should have it here.
[Laughs]
>> Georgia Higley: We do.
We do.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> Georgia Higley: All right.
Well, thank you very much.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
[ Applause ]
>>Gail Shirazi: I want to thank
Asaf, and I want to thank Georgia
for the very interesting program.
And we hope you will
come to our next one.
Thank you.
And we have some comic books
here if you want to take a look.
>> Asaf Galay: Yes.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.